So let's get back to this example, where I would sing about this concept, and
we want to know if it's going to help students learn and increase their
engagement. But let's pretend that after I sing, the 20 students exposed to
this lesson report a mean engagement score of 7.13. So remember, they're rating
their engagement from 1 to 10, and then we're going to take the average rating
of those 20 students, and we get 7.13. For now, let's not focus on student
learning. So first of all, what should the z score be for this sample mean?
Just to remind you we're pretending that the population mean was 7.5, and the
population standard deviation was 0.64. So, remember, when we find the z score
of a sample mean, we look at it compared to the whole sampling distribution